let's talk about making mistakes because
entrepreneurs do not ask for permission
generally speaking okay
they
they attune themselves they calibrate
themselves to ask for forgiveness
there's a big difference between asking
for forgiveness and asking for
permission asking for permission is yo
may i please do something
okay asking for forgiveness is that
didn't work out now i need to say sorry
to
a regulator a supplier a customer
whatever right
um
entrepreneurs ask for forgiveness they
don't ask for permission there's of
course times where asking for permission
is absolutely necessary but generally
speaking and you can get guidance from a
lawyer on this when you know you start
to grow a business asking for permission
is a loser's game you want to find
somebody that's going to advise you
uh a board of directors a law firm
a
accountant that leans more into asking
for forgiveness even though they do like
to cross their tees and dot their eyes
those are the most innovative type of
professionals that you want on your
board advising you so that you get those
good results
how you guys liking the show so far give
me a thumbs up
uh which brings me to the next point
don't worry about being perfect okay
entrepreneurs
good entrepreneurs will launch an
imperfect product now
rather than wait 12 14 months to uh put
out a perfect product i got to get my my
buddy thomas on playing the win
you guys are not going to know who he is
but you're going to want to watch the
episode
but he uh he had a nice exit and he was
setting up a new business like he took a
bit of a sabbatical for a year or two
and then he started to set up another
business with his business with his uh
same business partners again
and what ended up happening was um
they were basically taking too long
because they wanted to deliver a perfect
product
and
um
you know he went to his advisors and we
all talked to him
and was just like dude you have to
understand something when it comes to
products especially in the tech space
because it was a text based product
if you don't launch something
and it's a good idea
right you're gonna you're gonna trip
across uh
three
like young entrepreneurs with a case of
red bull and a bunch of boners just
going at it hardcore right
you have to you have to get out a viable
product
that's working and you can perfect it
later on down the road or you can add to
it you know a minimum viable product
that works that might have a couple
small bugs where you're going to do the
add-ons with the software updates later
on down the road with your other
pieces of technology is totally fine
right but waiting for
too long you're going to get surpassed
by somebody else especially if it's a
good idea because
somebody will come across it word will
get out something
if you can be first to market especially
with something that's new always a good
thing
uh what i got here early launching is
sorry early launching and imperfect
viable products is better than late
launching a perfect one
um
here's another good mindset point which
you really really want to consider you
want to be addicted to winning and be
allergic to losing
i don't remember where i heard this
but it was [ __ ] profound
a lot of people quit
um
being an entrepreneur is not easy
it can be
you know your chances of being
successful i mean let me put it to
this way
first time around you're going to fail 9
out of 10 times
second time round
if you have a good experience you know
you have a good exit or maybe you sell
it or even if you have to wind it down
you know that's a reasonable exit as
well
second time around the chances of
success are even higher so as you do it
more and more or as you get more and
more involved the chances of winning go
up
and you want to be addicted to that win
you want to be able to
nurture through it sort of thing you
know like to kind of get into the next
level
and you want to stay away from anything
that's going to potentially um
make you adopt a loser's mindset
um allergies suck i don't have too many
allergies i think i might have some dust
allergies you know at worst which might
cause a little bit of sneezing but i've
seen people with bad allergies they got
to stay away from peanuts they got like
some people got to leave the country
between
early september and late october because
of uh ragweed season in canada it's
[ __ ] horrible and some people suffer
terribly
you want to stay away from
losing you want to stay away from it
basically to the point where you're so
allergic to it you just repel it out of
your life it's not acceptable if that
makes sense hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you